good day and welcome everyone i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this
edition of our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture is supported by uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences the school of data
science
and through a grant from the national
institutes of general medical sciences
it is my honor and my privilege today to
welcome our speaker dr
david kennedy from the university of
massachusetts dr kennedy is a professor
of psychiatry at the university of
massachusetts medical school
he is the director of the division of
neuroinformatics at the child and
adolescent neurodevelopmental initiative
called candy he has extensive experience
in the development of image
analytic techniques and was a co-founder
of the center for morphometric analysis
at mass general hospital his career has
seen the advent of such
technologies as mr-based morphometric
analysis in 1989
the arrival of functional mri in 1991
and the development of diffusion tensor
pathway analysis
in 1998. he has a long-standing
experience with the development of
neuroinformatics resources and
participation in the morphometry
biomedical informatics resource network
or
mburn dr kennedy is the community
liaison for the neuroimaging
informatics tools and resources
clearinghouse called nitric
a fantastic resource for all manner of
software
and executables that deal with
neuroimaging related informatics
in addition he is the founding editor of
the journal of neural informatics that
debuted in 2003
and a pi of repronym the center for
reproducible neuroimaging computation
dr kennedy's lecture today is entitled
repronym towards reproducible
neuroimaging neuroscience
as always we are stringing this lecture
live and for recording via youtube if
you are watching via youtube
thank you so much for joining us today
also our specially selected 2020 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants are encouraged to submit
any questions for dr kennedy
by the chat feature in their zoom
sessions i will synthesize these
questions
and ask them on your behalf during the
last 10 minutes or so of the lecture
and with that welcome david we are very
much looking forward to your lecture
thank you so much jack it's my pleasure
to uh join you
uh in this you know exquisite seminar
series
and uh as you're mentioning it's part of
a long-standing
uh education and outreach effort that uh
again you've just been
monumental in spearheading so i
appreciate the the invitation
um the introduction you provided
uh while nice uh means only two things
one i'm old
uh but two uh when i was young there
were some really cool things going on
and so i was a very fortunate
person to be in the right place at the
right time during a development of
all of the sort of cool you know mri
based you know neuroimaging
methodologies so that was
an opportunity so um
the key driving uh topic i'd like to
talk about today is reproducibility
uh and again it's motivated by our nih
nibib funded uh center called reprem the
center for reproducible neural imaging
computation
uh so reproducibility will be my main
theme
uh and so i wanted to come up with you
know some sort of motivational
types of things now reproducibility is a
problem in lots of different you know
topics
we'll be specifically considering it in
the context of neuroimaging
but uh all the concepts and all the
issues really you know are
hand disciplinary in terms of other
fields and other
other you know approaches to brain and
and science in general
that you know need to keep these kinds
of concepts you know uh
you know in the front of one's mind but
uh by
focusing um i often come back to
uh so so my work tends to be in uh
psychiatric applications principally
child
uh psychiatric applications uh
development and
misdevelopment and uh autism and other
you know behavioral and developmental uh
disabilities
so since i work sort of on the
psychiatric side of things
uh one of my go-to you know statements
which really
motivates a lot of what i'll talk about
and a lot of what the center is really
working on
comes from a a paper by tom
insel and his colleagues tom insel at
the time was the head
of the national institutes of mental
health uh and he was sort of bemoaning
you know the lack of progress you know
in you know sort of mental health in
psychiatric
uh you know uh science you know
generally and while i hate to read a
long quote i think i do want to read
this one to make sure that
a couple points you know come out so
patients with mental disorders show many
biological abnormalities
which distinguish them from normal
volunteers however few of these have led
to tests with clinical utility
so again that's lamenting the fact that
you know today you know the clinical
tests we have in
psychiatric clinic are very similar to
what they were 10 20 30 years ago
before a vast investment in neuroimaging
a vast investment in genetics et cetera
so again we have very little new
clinical utility you know tests that
have come out of this investment
several reasons contribute to this delay
uh first there's a lack of a biological
gold standard
definition of psychiatric illnesses and
again this
you know uh portrays you know the shift
that the national institutes of mental
health had
back around this time from sort of
diagnoses
to research domains of classification so
again a lot of the
behaviors you know span diagnoses and
diagnoses tend to be
uh spectrums and checklists and things
like that
so not the best the sort of marker for
what you know is going on
behaviorally when it's a checklist you
know that you're giving you
that diagnosis so that really you know
launched you know this switch into
trying to find systems and circuits and
behaviors that go together
not uh a diagnosis you know that
ends up being the end target
a profusion you know of statistically
significant but minimally
differentiating
biological findings you know have
emerged and to this
you know we really mean that you know
over the past you know 25
30 years there's been tens of thousands
of papers and people have done
you know tens of thousands of studies
have found
you know things but
so lots of things get found but these
ultimately
are you know significant but not uh
you know informative in terms of you
know outcomes and you know
uh treatments and and types of things to
do
and this is you know confounded by the
fact that you know there are only
approximate
replications of these findings and
that's often done in ways that neither
confirm
nor refute those findings and so
in the end we end up generating lots of
data lots of papers lots of grants lots
of studies
but not lots of improvement in how and
how
the clinician treats the patient and how
the patient
you know the prognosis and the outcomes
you know for that patient
and so that was you know kind of you
know damning uh you know assessment
and really you know rather important you
know motivator how do we
try to improve you know on this you know
kind of state of the art back in
2012 or so uh so there's lots of reasons
you know that you know these you know
concerns you know are expressed
uh and we'll talk about them and and
look at issues of them but you know
certainly you know
we're using you know often low-powered
studies
uh we diagnosis is not a great target uh
we don't really you know
publish you know proper and complete
methods and results uh
and publication bias leads to you know
kind of a skewed literature and look at
each of those
sort of ramifications as we go through
this presentation
so again while i'm using sort of a
prototypical
uh analysis uh from the neural imaging
domain
uh hopefully you in radio listening land
can you
warp this into you know the appropriate
stages of your own you know type of work
but you know clearly we start with you
know some sort of uh
data acquisition and uh you know
activities and experiments
on subjects uh imaging you know things
like that generate a bunch of data
imaging data
behavioral data apply you know analyses
and workflows in order to generate some
derived data
and some statistical results and we go
off and publish those
and some of that data and all of that
uh literature you know become
distributed
you know in pubmed and other sort of
queryable you know places
so each of these stages you know have
different implications about you know
how we currently do those
and how those really can you know evolve
you know to trying to
to do a better job of you know improving
our infrastructure
for doing reproducible neuroimaging
neuroscience
um so coming back to one of those key
sub phrases of that insult you know
quote you know we have
approximate approximate replications of
you know the findings we tend to find
yeah in a way that neither confirms nor
refutes them
so again that is one of these you know
driving you know types of statements you
know and
you know three points you know come to
mind here first that it's impossible to
confirm or refute
something that you cannot first
replicate so if
i see a paper and i want to confirm it
or refute it uh
i'd better be able to start by being
able to replicate it
in order to see then you know if you
know
different data different uh approaches
you know
uh find that same result
second you know we tend to not publish
our findings you know with the necessary
details in order
to support replication so again the pdf
the traditional publication uh and word
counts
and you know readability and sort of the
human aspects of things
really are not commensurate you know
with the
highly digital highly you know complex
highly you know computational nature you
know of the
science that we're doing so by by the
definition you know of you know words
you know we're really not you know
providing all the necessary details
uh in our you know general way of
disseminating knowledge the
the publication so
the third point here is that when it
comes to examining
either re-execution or the
generalizability of an observation or a
claim
it turns out that every single decision
that we make every
choice you know everything we do matters
in terms of that output you know result
so just uh walk through a couple
examples of this and again i think it
you know
holds in many different contexts but
just to put some
examples onto that last statement
exactly what operating system computer
system
you're using you know can make a
difference in this case
uh a simple paper that we talked about
later in the presentation
it takes the exact same software fsl
version 5.09 uh the exact same data
data runs it in a mac operating system
runs it in an ubuntu operating system
and documents you know that you know the
you know the same measures that are
coming out of that same software you
know are different
as a function of of operating system now
there's ways to
ameliorate this but again it's important
to know that you know even
you're something as simple as what your
operating system is what your version of
software is
what um the version of the operating
system is
you can make you know differences in you
know what's the same data and the same
the same uh you know workflow
similarly and clearly not surprisingly
you know the data
you know how much data you have uh
matters you know in important ways
and the little example i use of this is
looking at the uh
sex effect of hippacampus volume uh in
typical
subjects we could go back to the state
of the literature back in 2005 or so
where you know the nih funded you know a
large
study at the time you know 325 uh
pediatric you know population
across seven sites and this is the
so-called nih pediatric uh
database you look at that data a
large database uh look at the sex effect
in the hippocampus volume and you see
you know sort of a zero effect but a
pretty large you know
error bars fast forward to 2011
where the ping the pediatric imaging
neurocognition and genetics
study you know gets published so that's
you know it's a 1200 study
1200 subjects from you know eight more
sites with a much more modern you know
imaging acquisition much more modern
segmentation technology
and lo and behold uh we now begin to see
you know a sex effect in the hippocampus
volume emerge
now this is not inconsistent with that
2005 and that it falls completely within
you know the confidence limits of those
original studies
but we've now tightened the error bars
and
you know been able to you know refine
the method refine the measurements
uh and get to a data size you know that
begins to let us you know observe
you know this this type of finding then
if you fast forward further to 2015
more you know publicly available data
becomes available
and then you can you know see that you
know that you know effect you know has
begun to sort of stabilize with
you know the new data that's becoming
available so again data size matters
but not only size you know sort of the
era and quality of data matters
so just because again i'm one of the
folks who you know pushes very hard for
lots and lots of data sharing you know
all along but again there is you know
data quality there is data age
effects and not all data is created
equal but again to assess that and
understand that
it's really better to you know have that
available and then to make the choice
and make those
rational decisions about how to use you
know that information
as it's shared the um
just a you know somewhat trivial but
informative you know exploration
you know of uh this you know number of
subjects type of issue
in this case is a simulation statistical
simulation we ran
using the ping data again ping is a
pediatric imaging
neurocognition and genetics you know
study ran out of uh
san diego terry jernigan andersdale had
12 000 subjects
and so sort of our final you know a
little observation over here
is you know uh sort of the expectation
of this about 200
cubic millimeter sex uh
based you know volumetric difference you
know in uh
males versus females in the volume of
hippocampus
but you can you know easily do the
bootstrapping and sort of sub sampling
exercises and if you had uh
you know studies of select you know only
you know 10 subjects from that uh 10
males 10 females and redo the analysis
and permute that you know thousands of
times you get this you know kind of
distribution
you know of you know effect sizes that
you would observe
uh pick you know 250 sub sub subjects
you know run that permutation
this is the distribution of you know
effect sizes that you see
so ultimately and all we're doing is you
know actually you know demonstrating you
know the power
you know uh calculation in terms of an
effect size which is about
200 you know cubic millimeters and a
measure
of a certain you know variance the free
surfer hippocampus volume measurement in
you know uh healthy you know children
you know across the
you know 5 to 21 you know age range and
we see that for
you know effect of 200 millimeters you
really need to have you know a 200 or
250 you know subject you know size
you know before you begin to clearly you
know clear that significance you know of
that effect and that distribution
so again not rocket science here but it
reminds us that again when when we're
looking at small things
when we're looking at moderately large
population variants
you know we really do need to get into
orders of magnitude larger studies than
we had been doing
you know sort of in the old days and so
again that n
you know that you know tends to be
needed for even sort of a mod
moderate or moderate to small effect
size you know it's an important thing to
keep in mind
and how that you know relates to the
types of studies and the subtleties of
you know
cognition and uh uh mental health you
know that we're trying to
disentangle relative to larger effects
such as
sex and age and socioeconomic status and
genetic ancestry etc
so uh the next in line in the everything
matters uh
rant is what tool you select you know
matters
so while on the one hand we might be
looking at the volume of you know a
cortical region the left caudal anterior
cingulate
uh in this case there's at least there's
more but
we're looking at two different tools one
called ants and one called free surfer
uh both of which make a measure of the
left
anterior cingulate uh volume
uh and in this case we have two versions
of free surfer version 5.1 and 5.3
and we have one version of this ants
software
so the good news is you know free surfer
between
versions has a very tight you know
correlation so they didn't do anything
in version 5.3 to muck up
you know the measurements relative to
what they were doing in 5.1
on the other hand the two freezer for
measures relative to the ants measures
while statistically significantly
correlated
uh are really correlated at not an
exceedingly
you know high um uh
you know fidelity so while statistically
correlated
you know these really are not you know
exceedingly well
and representative of this of the same
data now this is we're fortunate here
that this is you know
800 and some subjects so we can you know
see this you know correlation but but
again
the the one measurement is not really a
you know great
proxy you know for the other measurement
and so therefore a concept
such as the volume of the left caudal
anterior cingulate you know is really
rather different
if you're looking at it from the point
of view of free server versus you know
ants
so therefore the types of findings and
things you might see
you know could be could be different and
so i'll use that
uh as a jumping off place to
demonstrate okay fine you know they
correlate significantly but
it doesn't matter well the answer is yes
and i'll illustrate that
but i'll also illustrate it in the
context of something called siegel's law
so siegel's law goes something like a
man with a watch
knows what time it is so in this case uh
if my watch
you know is free surfer i have one watch
my watch is freezer for 5.3
the time the analog of time here is i'm
measuring
in this case you know in the abide the
autism brain image data exchange
i'm looking at the effect of the
diagnosis of autism or not
uh based on the volume of a set of you
know 48 different
cortical regions so my one watch is free
surfer
i the time i'm measuring is you know how
different is
the volume of this region in the subject
with autism versus subjects without
autism
and i find you know a nice set of you
know regions you know that have a
diagnosis effect and a bunch of regions
you know that don't
so this is just rank ordered on the
effect size and you know that's
the time so to speak the second part
of siegel's law though is but a person
with two watches
is never sure because you know in
general two watches are never exactly
the same and so if you have two watches
you don't know which one
is right or either right uh so having
two watches you don't really know
you know at all exactly what time it is
and again the analog in this case
uh is the effect that we saw you know
before that you know free surfer and
ants you know ants is our second watch
uh the time we're measuring is the
you know effect of you know the
diagnosis you know of autism
and we see that our second watch gives
us a
rather different you know view of time
of you know where the difference is you
know in the brain volumes are
in the subjects with autism versus um
you know typical controls now again my
point here is not to argue about which
is right or wrong
my argument here is to make sure that
we're
acutely aware that different tools you
know
even if they're measuring nominally the
same thing you know uh
have different biases have different you
know assumptions uh and can give you
know
different views and so the observation
you know of you know differences is
really you know
predicated upon the exact tools exact
tool selection
you know that goes on and sometimes we
forget that so that's part of the point
of you know making sure that we keep
that in mind
uh and clearly again as well you know
exactly what statistics one uses you
know matters
so in this little simulation we go back
to looking at our fun uh
hippocampus uh sex effect uh
we're looking at the ping data so it's
about 1200 subjects
we have a grand you know
volume as a function of sex is related
to
age sight socioeconomic socioeconomic
status
total brain volume and genetic ancestry
factor so those are all the
uh covariates you know that we could use
and all these are known to have
some effect you know in the measurements
of brain volumes
so we essentially permute you know
create an ensemble of these models
you know one model that only has age one
model that only has site one model that
only has
scs and a set of models that have you
know two of these age inside
age and ses age and total brain volume
uh
et cetera so we create sort of all the
different permutations
of these models that could exist and ask
what is the sex effect
given that you know ensemble of
different models
and so here we're plotting the effect
size you know on the x-axis so this is
an effect size of you know
600 or so and this little grouping here
has an effect size about 200 you know or
so
um and then the y-axis here is the r
squared sort of a goodness of fit
you know representation so what we see
when we just plot all
you know 128 of those models the
permutations
of you know this set of factors is we
see these two little clusters
this one cluster has a large effect and
this one cluster has a much
smaller effect and the only difference
between these two clusters is when
you know brain volume is included as a
covariate now that makes complete sense
you know
sex is related to brain volume itself so
if we
discount you know the brain volume
difference between sex
uh we get left with you know a
you know radically different you know
representation so again this
you know big example you know covering
for brain volume makes you know a huge
difference in that
it makes sense it also varies with sex
so you know that that's fine
um but more interestingly so each of
these
circles is the uh effect size estimate
uh and the whiskers then are the 95 you
know confidence limit
on that effect size estimate and so
within here
you know again we're seeing a cluster
and many of these
uh models are significant you know i.e
their whiskers you know don't touch
you know the zero effect size but not
all of them
so some subset of these um models you
know
if that was the model you happen to
choose are going to end up you know not
being significant
whereas a different subset of those
models will end up you know being
significant
so again i'm not here to debate exactly
what the right model is
but only to use this as an illustration
of you know again exactly what model
we're using
uh can affect what does or doesn't you
know end up being portrayed
as significant and also some of these
models you know
are much better at predicting you know
the overall variance of the data
compared to others so again when we took
out brain volume we you know
doubled you know our you know ability to
you know accurately
you know model the data but we also you
know dramatically reduced
you know the effect size of of sex on
hippocampal volume here
but again that's closer to reality since
we didn't want the total brain volume
you know interfering with that
observation of of you know the sex
effect
you know in the hippocampal volume so
again lots to
worry about in terms of what the right
you know model is what the
right approach to modeling when there's
lots of covariates and lots of things
that you know
you know also have significant effects
on the observation
of interest
so fine there's a bunch of sources of
variants that i've
illustrated for you but you know that's
why we have the big literature that's
why we publish lots of things you know
these sources of variability will work
themselves out in the publish
literature right well no
uh and for a couple reasons we tend not
to publish negative findings
uh and that has to do with things like
publication bias and file drawer effect
that we could talk about further you
know later if one wanted to
uh so that a given published false
positive
may not see much contra indication to it
because you know people don't want to
publish you know the fact that you know
that region didn't you know
show up they'll usually go and look for
something else that did show up and
publish that
so when we see something when we do see
something that's different it usually
gets wished away
with you know statements like oh you
know our population of you know autism
subjects is a little bit different or
oh we use the different methods so it's
okay that you know we're getting you
know
different answers and so now the
literature then you know
gets you know a second answer and a
third answer and the fourth answer
that are a little bit different and all
implicating you know sort of different
regions and never coming back and
asking ourselves why are we not seeing
or are we not seeing you know some of
the common
regions across these this different set
of publications
and again so a trivial or simple
illustration of that
is you know my finding i look at these
two regions region a and region b
region a is important and significant i
report that in literature
yay you come along with your paper uh
you don't see anything in region a
but in your case ah reason b is
important so you publish you know region
b
you know is important so now both of
these may be false positives you know
due to low power or
or whatever but our literature doesn't
know that our literature doesn't know
our inconsistency our literature just
has you know region a is important and
region b
is important you know in this disorder
and along we go
you know merrily next person who finds
you know region b
looks through literature and says oh yes
you know so-and-so saw that i'm
consistent with the literature
ignoring of course the fact that you
know someone else you know didn't see
that so again these
ability to constructively or
destructively interfe
you know sum up you know these different
findings is really just not happening
properly in the literature you know as
as we reported
so and that
builds upon itself you know in a
literature uh and one of my favorite
examples
you know of you know kind of a
semi-pervasive effect
certainly in the volumetric literature
uh is
documented in this um publication here
by anne lefevre
and roberto torro uh
in this case they're looking at uh what
was felt to be a pretty stable
finding uh that across you know lots of
publications
in the autism literature if you look at
the corpus callosum volume
you find you know significant decrease
in corpus closum volume
as a function of autism so again if you
just read the literature
you know you read lots of articles you
can find lots of articles you know that
support that idea
fine you can then go off and do a proper
you know meta analysis of that
literature
and that's you know shown here there's
uh
14 you know different publications and
you do the meta-analysis on this effect
and you get a significant you know
effect
you know of the literature and you say
yep that's what i expected that's what i
feel like when i read the literature
all is well with the world the
literature is consistent on that despite
you know some
saying the effect is really big and some
saying the effect doesn't exist
in general the literature suggests you
know the effect is about a
0.5 uh standardized mean difference
so uh what roberto torres group did was
you know try to conf
you know confirm that so if that was a
true fine finding
one would like to be able to see that
not just you know in the retrospective
published literature
but in a prospective you know set large
you know data set of
of data about you know subject with
autism and so in this case using the
abide the autism brain
image data exchange data they uh found
you know 694 subjects uh in the seven to
forty you know year old age range
uh 328 our patients uh 304
you know our our control i'm sorry 366
our controls
ran a particular software package free
surfer 5.1
and looked at this corpus closum effect
well uh the types of things they observe
were things that you would expect you
know there was a significant side effect
and that's been
seen and this came from about uh
probably about 20 sites so it's a large
number of sites
to generate this data set but there was
a significant side effect
there was as expected a significant age
effect
and there was as expected a significant
uh sex effect
but uh unfortunately the
they did not confirm you know a group
effect a diagnosis effect
of this um you know corpus callosum
volume
um and uh the diagnosis of
of autism so that's you know upsetting
and that you know something that was so
clear you know from the traditional
published literature that there should
be an effect
you know couldn't be replicated in a
prospective um
uh mega analysis as opposed to the
retrospective meta meta-analysis
so it turns out there's a good number of
reasons and background to this and i
don't
dwell too long but part of the point is
power
the biggest of those prior studies was
113
you know subjects the biggest power
to see an effect of you know 0.3 you
know
standardized uh effect size was only 36
percent
so in general all of those
publications that we're seeing this uh
effect were woefully underpowered you
know to
you know see that effect uh and if there
were an effect
of that size there really ought to be
you know many many many
more you know publications or
observations you know that that did not
see it
so again this is an example probably of
you know this uh
publication bias of and uh uh reporting
you know bias whereas the mega analysis
that was performed
you know had a 99 power to detect an
effect of of this you know 3.3 standard
deviations
um and yet this is the publication that
did not you know
see this so the scarcity of negative
results is a problem and the
woefully under in retrospect the willful
underpoweredness
of the literature that went into that
original meta analysis you know
is is you know problematic
so ultimately what you know this kind of
refers to
is not that nothing is going on in the
corpus closum
but the model of that sort of simply
diagnosis
you know relates to you know corpus
callosum volume is really too limited to
model
and you know these studies were
underpowered to look at sort of the
covariate
sort of the whole system of what's going
on here is that you know diagnosis
you know is related to brain volume
diagnosis is related to iq
iq is you know also related to the brain
volume
and so all of these things you know are
co-varying together
and you know so yes there is an effect
in corpus callosum
but if you control properly for ice q
and control properly
for brain volume uh that effect is not
necessarily a direct
effect of diagnosis and corpus callosum
so again by getting to properly
you know sized studies to be able to
more you know efficiently
you know disentangle you know the types
of covariates that are going on
one can change you know the view of you
know sort of what the causality or what
the
relationship you know in that uh model
will be
how are we doing one time okay um
so fine lots of things are a problem
i always get yelled at for being a
rather pessimistic person and
most of my um uh research associates you
know get very annoyed with me for being
so so negative so
let's try to turn a little bit more
positive here
so steps to recovery doing truly
reproducibility
reproducible neuroimaging research is
hard there are just so many things that
we've seen
that you have to do you know to get it
right
so that's where sort of repronym has
been trying to focus you know a lot of
our efforts in terms of you know
establishing sort of a comprehensive set
of tools and practices
that are designed to advance the
reproducibility of each of these
critical stages
of the neuroimaging research process
so again i've sort of alluded to this
but i you know want to
say this even more explicitly is you
know reproduce what so there's at least
two domains of places where we're
concerned about reproducibility
i may want to reproduce in the sense of
re-execution
of a specific result so for a specific
paper
given the same data given the same
approach can i
re-execute that observation so in this
data set
with this tool can i confirm that the
hippocampus is 203 millimeters larger in
the boys and
the girls great that's interesting and
useful
not very scientifically you know
exciting but
uh sort of an important you know
founding foundation
point the slightly more interesting
scientific question is reproduce
in the sense of generalizing of the
claim that when i use
different but similar data and a
different but similar approach
can i generalize can i reproduce the
same
you know claim that you know came from
my original observation
so the general claim you know might be
something like hippocampa are larger in
boys and girls
uh and to generalize that you know i
need you know additional data to confirm
you know the claim that may have come
from my
you know first observation for that to
generalize in the literature or across
you know other observations you know use
additional data
use additional tools that look at uh
volume and if all of those
you know cooperate then we can begin to
generalize and reproduce the claim that
inhibited
by indeed are larger in boys than girls
but if there was something about
you know the measurement of fifa
campaign or something about how i
claim uh how i what i meant you know by
boys versus girls or what the age limits
are or things like that you know might
matter
and so therefore one may have to be
careful in how they
distinguish the groups by which you know
this observation this claim
you know holds over and so again so all
sorts of things just have to be
a bit more careful than we tend to tend
to be
so fine a different version of the same
thing is this you know original
data the original paper you write you
know has some data has some analysis has
some result
we argue that what we're missing the
first thing we're missing
is this concept of re-executability and
i'm
guilty of this especially because i'm so
old and i've been doing so many studies
for so long
that i probably cannot get to the same
data from a study i did
and get to that same analysis and verify
that i can get the exact same result
from a paper
five years 10 years 20 years ago so we
really
you know i and i think semi exemplary of
the
of the literature you know are not you
know really engaging in science and
in the way that you know we can at least
establish you know the sort of core
re-executability of my original finding
but having that re-executability in
place is really the necessary
you know foundation point for
systematically
and you know sort of scientifically
exploring the generalization
of my claim so can we muck around with
similar analyses
on that same data and get a similar
result does the tool matter
uh can i you know use that exact same
you know
analysis and use similar data you know
you know my kids with autism compared to
your kids with autism
if the finding really is related to
autism it shouldn't matter if it's my
set of kids or your set of kids if it's
really about you know volume
it shouldn't matter if i'm using this
tool or that tool if these are valid
valid tools so ultimately we want to get
to the
generalization statement that you know
similar data and similar analyses
should yield that similar result but
we'd like to be able to do that in a
systematic way
and not you know as we kind of right now
we have my paper
and we have your paper which is on
similar data and similar
analyses but we can't rationally
you know understand the differences when
i don't replicate and we don't know
and uh which you know often happens and
this is because we don't really
characterize our data and our analysis
and our results very well in our current
literature and this idea of similar has
lots of
wiggle room and how one can use that
into their own purposes
again if you're trying to write some if
you had you know two functional you know
mri experiments and each had a foci of
activation
you know close but not quite overlapping
well if you wanted to tout the novelty
of your uh approach you could say ah
my approach and their approach get in
completely different spots because they
don't overlap
great if you had a reason that you
wanted to you know say the similarity of
these results
well you know those two spots yeah
they're close they're part of the same
system i'll say
there and you know there's you know
anatomic variability so again at
the behest of the writer one can often
you know take
results and decide if it suits them
better to call them
similar or dissimilar to to their to
their purposes
and again this happens just because we
can't get to the exact answers
and the exact methods you know to both
of those types of observations and
really use those in a systematic
fashion so the steps to recovery
really uh i'll try to illustrate you
know by example
here and then work backwards to how we
might you know get there
a traditional publication uh publishes
some
traditional you know correlation
analyses
we see a pdf you know plot you know we
see a bunch of observations we see a
you know fit somewhere in the text you
know they tell us all the details of how
the data was analyzed and how the
statistic was done and what the
magnitude of the
effect was and you know blah blah blah
lovely you read it and you're happy
the repronum variant of that really
wants to
shift uh you know do a sort of paradigm
shift under how we
do that same publication uh in sort of
the
reproducible re-executable fashion so in
a reproductive version of this you know
same plot
each point knows in some canonical sense
you know all sorts of information about
where that point came from it's
provenance
who was the subject you know that that
point is representative of
what was the demographics what were the
clinical variables etc what mri scan was
used you know to generate
you know that you know observation what
was the scanner what was the acquisition
retails and where is that scan living
you know at the moment on my hard drive
out in some public repository uh
what workflow was used you know that
took you know that mri scan
and turned it into this you know volume
of a corpus callosum
measurement and this is a volume of a
corpus callosum measurement well where
does that fit into the
constellations of measures you know what
is a volume what is the corpus callosum
what part of the
you know brains that belong to how does
it relate to other other parts of the
brain
so all of those are features of every
point that we should be able to generate
and if we just keep the provenance and
keep the annotations
about that point as we generate it they
each know point
you know can then you know sort of
recreate itself that point
knows what workflow what generated it
that workflow you know can exist in a
container or somewhere that can be you
know re-executed
so given that point it can be
regenerated by anyone
who had the container and the ability to
execute that given that you know you can
get to that data
and you can get to that specification
that could be you know
anyone could re-execute that it also
supports then the concept of
generalizability
if i take different data i can do the
exact same analysis
if i you know take that same data and
you know open up
that container i can change the tool i
can change the parameters
on that and so be able to you know
explore the generalization
of that point because all of its history
all of its execution all of its
generation
you know can be captured in a formal way
uh and in that sense the point is fair
uh in that in some way you know
that point can be housed locally or
publicly in a way that's findable
accessible interoperable and reusable
and hopefully that will resonate a bit
with uh marianne martone's
presentation from from a while back uh
so fine
if we can generate points in that way
that would be great uh
the statistic has the same issue the
statistic you know
has a version has a you know
an execution has a container in which it
runs so
given that this pilot data uh this
statistic can be rerun
given a different pile of data the exact
same statistic can be run
given you know the same or different
pile of data one can
you know has the framework to then
version control and track
and understand differences that one
might make
in that analysis approach
great um so
that i just set up sort of a wish that
you know gee yeah what would i have to
do
to make all of the provenance and all
the metadata for each of my observations
and each of the you know
statistics and interpretations of that
observation you know so what do i have
to do
to actually accomplish you know that uh
and that's hard
so one of the things reaper nym has also
tried to do is to stratify
the process into individual components
each of which
individually are not as hard as the
whole you know thing
and each can be adopted individually and
each contribute to the overall
reproducibility of the research effort
effort so the reprint platform is a sort
of a virtual path
through lots of different components
that we try to improve you know sort of
piece by piece one's ability to do these
things just because it'll be hard to do
everything at once and start a whole new
study and do it this way
but if we can get you to do simple
things that are a little bit better than
what you did in your prior paper
and then through your sequence of you
know learning and and doing things a
little bit better
you know we all can sort of improve the
background and the
underpinnings you know of the published
you know literature that we that we
generate
so the stages of research that we you
know dwell upon you know the sort of
five
you know steps that we'll refer to
there's studies design data collection
data processing statistical analysis and
the publication the principles that we
try to
apply to each of these stages include
you know sort of proper planning
proper version control use of standards
uh
annotation and archival and so
in each of these different stages we at
reapernym
and you know the community as a whole
have a number of different tools and and
resources that are
you know available to assist in you know
sort of promoting
you know sort of the reproducible uh
execution
of each of these uh different stages so
in terms of study design
you know you might in the planning stage
you might really encourage you know
pre-registration
uh version control really cuts across
everything
as you do your study design that may
evolve but we better
understand why and when it evolves so
you know what it is you know you end up
doing
and there's annotation you know that can
be done with the neural imaging data
modeling similarly in collection we want
version control taken care of so there's
tools like data lab we want
standards such as repro in and bids you
know to be used we want
annotation to really describe what it is
we're acquiring and we want to do that
at the time of acquisition
uh because it's easier to do when you're
designing and
uh collecting the data than it is to do
five or ten years later when you go to
publish it and can't remember what
the sam three variable you know really
means
uh and there's tools for archival and we
don't go into the details of this
there's
lots of tools and lots of resources you
know that
can be applied to sort of each of these
different uh areas
and again we could talk further about
those tools specifically
if they are important or interesting to
anyone so
again a second version of uh seeing the
same thing uh
you know has to do with so these five
steps that we we mentioned
and you know a set of tools you know
that really support you know doing them
and again the point here is that you
don't have to do everything correct uh
most reproducibly to start with pick
something oh i want to do my uh
data analysis you know using datalab
okay well do that and that's you know
better off than you were before
oh i want to use version control for my
scripts okay use git
and do that and you know each of these
singular things you know are
steps to you know overall improvement of
the
of the overall system so the last
concept
is fine we talked conceptually about you
know wanting re-executability at the
paper level
we talked about a bunch of tools that
are available you know for
for doing elements you know of that so
where does this bring us where we end up
uh we end up in this concept of the
repro pub
which uh is this re-executable
publication and of the future
is slightly i mean you can do it today
uh but again a lot of our efforts are
trying to make it you know more
routine you know to do these sort of
completely re-executable publications
now what do we have to do to do a new
version of a publication that is
re-executable
well yes we need humans to read it and
understand it and like
you know the study you did so we need
our words but we need to include
additional digital machine readable
supplementary you know information
we need to explicitly indicate what data
went into
the analysis we need to explicitly
define
you know the exact details of the
workflow specification we need to
ex explicitly and completely define the
execution environment
you know that supported the running of
that analysis and we have to provide
that complete set of results
not just the story you'd tell about it
because that makes a good story
and that's important but the complete
set of results is what's necessary in
order to one
verify you know that it's re-executable
and two to support
the negative findings and the
anti-findings and the uh
mixing and matching of findings you know
across the complete set as opposed to
the
garden path story that uh you know you
tell about the results that you make
sense you know to you
so you know we need sort of a completely
executable research publication that
requires the complete description
the provenance you know of the data
workflow execution
environment and results so we've done a
couple examples
of this the first one we refer to as
simple one
uh which uh was really you know just you
know
you know 20 subjects from the nitric
that are imaging informatics tools and
resources clearinghouse publicly
available data
a very simple fsl you know volume
workflow
run in a you know very simple uh ubuntu
you know container
built with neurodoctor uh and so the
data you know is a data set which is you
know identifiable and you know machine
readable machine accessible the workflow
and the results
you know are in a github repo that's
been uh
archived into a specific you know doi
you know through zenodo
and the execution environment is a
particular container
that lives at you know docker hub so
anyone you know could
read this paper get to the data get to
the workflow
get the environment and verify that they
could generate the same results and this
was done in a very simple situation so
you could
you know if you wanted to to do that and
to verify that you got the
the right answer uh so to some extent
one doesn't really want
to do that but one wants to know that
they can you know do that and wants to
be able to
represent you know publications in that
way
but this is a silly paper it didn't
really do anything scientifically it
just
demonstrated the concepts of these of
these pieces and the
their connectivity in a traditional
publication
that can still accompany with these
accompanying documents
uh achieve this this objective
so a more complex example that i'll end
on here is uh
you know trying to do that same thing
but actually do it in a biologically
interesting thing so we
searched the literature for iq and
typically developing children
discovered uh three different papers
that you know did some
tasks did some observations of iq and
structural variables
uh so we given uh we need to discover
you know our own data that's uh
appropriate for that
we need to prepare that data in a
semantically appropriate way we need to
select a workflow that makes the
measurements that we need
uh we need to execute that workflow we
need to make sure our results are
represented in that
semantic representation and then we need
to query that and do the statistics you
know that verify or
replicate you know the findings that we
know developed from the literature
so again in this case we can do that
with pre-registration of hypotheses that
came from literature
we have a structural workflow that you
know is using neurodoctor to
containerize a free surfer an fsl
and an ants uh you know software and
that container
you know and workflow is available the
data sets come from abide one and adhd
200
publicly available uh and the
statistical analysis and results
you know are published you know as a as
a jupiter notebook so again we've
accomplished the same things
of yes we can write lovely words about
this but each of those elements
in addition to the human readable words
are associated with
machine re-executable you know elements
and so this is just one of the
hypotheses that total brain volume will
positively correlate with iq
in both sexes across the complete age
range here's the data
uh we found you know uh a significant
you know effect here and the original
report had a significant effect here of
a very similar sort of magnitude
so cool we re-executed that the old
report
you know was not re-executable this one
is and so anyone could take our version
of that
yes it's nice that it re-recreated the
prior
expectation but ours you know can now
live and you know be added to or
manipulated as as as one sees fit so
overall in these three papers there were
nine
hypotheses you know that were generated
uh and
you know six of those you know we
replicated in the abide in adhd 200 data
but three of the findings that were you
know
you know from the literature didn't
replicate
and so again so one can now
yes that's sad that this didn't
replicate and we can't really
again they use different data than we
did and we used a slightly different
tool than they did so we know
this differences but at least from our
version of this you know one can now
expand and explore that uh in ways that
you couldn't
if you failed to replicate you know
their observation you know
originally so final slide
uh so uh for some reason
this uh dawned on me that you know i
should end with the wrath of
of god or the wrath of the nih and you
know uses fear factor
ending reproducibility just do it or
else you know you won't get funding
we know there are new data policies
coming from the nih you know that are
going into effect which are much more
stringent in terms of data management
and data sharing
even now progress reports and uh
competing renewals and things like that
can be held up or you know not awarded
if you're not doing your
data sharing data acquisition you know
appropriately
you won't get published if you don't
work on reproducibility many journals
are now beginning to
you know enhance their data sharing and
software sharing policies
uh and if you can't get funding and you
can't get published you won't get tenure
that's semi a joke since most people
don't really get 10 years these days
anyway but that's okay
but most importantly john oliver will
laugh at you uh there's a whole lovely
segment on
on the this week with john oliver you
know lamenting how badly you know many
scientific studies and how badly the
the news media deals with uh
scientific studies that are done in
irreducible fashions
um and then so ultimately you adopt
reproducibility by design
that's much easier than doing
reproducibility at the end
and i thank lots of folks from the
reaper nymph team
uh and the many institutions and the
many uh
groups you know that work with us and we
are available
uh via websites emails twitters monthly
webinar training materials youtube
channel etc and
thank you i'm sorry a little bit longer
than i probably should have
david thank you very much for that uh
fantastic
uh overview of the importance of
reproducibility what it means for for
science and
and all the the effort that you guys
have put into not only
sharing your ideas but your code and
your
uh tools for so doing i think it's great
um
one couple of questions so um i was
impressed by looking at some of the
meta-analytics summaries that you
provided and
you had mentioned publication bias as
one of the sources and
i've published in this area a little bit
myself especially in neuroimaging and so
i have a little
my own thoughts about this but i wanted
to pick your brain a little bit about
the sources of publication bias
in neuroimaging for example um
what are some of the sources of that and
also would we do better by not just
reporting small
p values and saying oh look something
was statistically significant but
doing a better job of reporting effect
sizes power estimates
and stressing what is there beyond just
a small p
value does that make sense yes uh that
makes sense
i think there's a lot of impetus
to get away from maybe not abolish not
defund you know p
values but really you know downplay
p-values and make sure that effect sizes
are reported
make sure that power is reported because
again to some extent you know
so much of what we and again the two
issues with power
is there's retrospective power you
calculate from your observation
which you know if you're have found a
you know spurious false positive
you're going to miscalculate the power
anyway uh
but uh again looking at the difference
between you know
prospective power and retrospective
power and what the what that is and
we'll find that
an offline findings we do have are
rather significantly underpowered
doesn't mean they're wrong but it means
you know their positive predictive value
the
likelihood of seeing that again in a new
study
you know is not as good as you know an
observation that came in a
better powered study so again i think
yeah there's a lot of movement towards
you know effect sizes
and you know observed power and you know
really
grappling with and just embracing or
understanding and working with the fact
that you know things are underpowered
and
you know need this replication so while
i sometimes sound
negative about you know small
underpowered studies not everyone can do
10 000 you know 10 year olds and follow
them for the next 10 years to look at
everything you want to do
i can't be against you know small
underpowered studies what i am against
is small underpowered studies that are
done in sort of a private you know
closed you know space that no one that
don't have a chance of you know being
contributed into the bigger literature
to become part of a properly powered
prospective study
so that i think is the problem is you
know closed low-powered
uh studies not the presence of low-power
studies i think that's in fact
you know the nhs won't fund things that
are big enough
and to report power to report effect
size and publication bias
there's so much
requirement you know to publish uh and
even if one isn't
you know actively p hacking you know
there's just lots of
you know i don't say laziness but lots
of things that people do which are not
quite as
you know copacetic in the long term uh
in part just because
again myself included i didn't really
know any better and were quite anxious
you know to find something you know to
publish out of this
and i think the pre-registration
therefore becomes an important part of
that
to help uh avoid some of the publication
bias to help promote
the uh publishing of negative findings
and again the challenge with negative
findings is you have to be properly
powered again negative findings don't
magically overcome the power issue
you can be equally underpowered for a
negative finding as well so again all
these things just need to be more
transparent
more published uh so that they can be
put together and built upon and
understood with respect to each other
more efficiently fantastic i
i liked how you your funnel slide there
about what are some of the incentives
for
reproducible science and you when
there's the carrot and the stick
kind of classification if i will um
one of the things i'm curious about
though is is in thinking about how
data scientists um and people who are
involved in
computational um uh the enterprise
of the brain as a computational science
um
what can their role being uh be in
per you know helping to support
reproducible brain science
you're muted my friend yeah
someone has to do that in every
presentation right yeah um that's right
and the answer i gave that for a second
was was spot on so i'll just uh
yeah um the uh
not gonna it takes a village in the
sense that you know we as authors
just need to be aware of this we as you
know grant writers you know need to be
aware of this we as reviewers of grants
reviewers of publications
need to um step up you know our review
uh criteria
we as you know editors or or um
you know leaders of you know publication
you know platforms
you know really need to embrace the
rigor you know side of this
again it's not that you can't publish
things that are underpowered et cetera
et
cetera
but we just need to be doing this you
know in a framework that you know
is you know constructive
you know as opposed to you know sort of
siloed into
individual publications and i'm not sure
if i answered the question you asked but
that was
well it just it seems that there's so
much opportunity for
data scientists who are very interested
in developing tools that help promote
a science of reproducibility within the
science of the brain
um a huge opportunity for that and so
the whether it's the development of
ontologies or
computational tools or frameworks for
how publications
gets uh reported uh in the you know in
2021
i think there's enormous opportunity i i
think you'd uh be one of the first
people to
agree yes absolutely and just because we
have a handful of tools
i meant to say and perhaps did say that
someone said i don't care how
you get your version controlling or how
you get your annotation or how we have
some tools for that would be nice if you
used ours
as long as you get your data into
standards that others can use it as long
as you
report the provenance of what you've
done so that others can re-execute it
uh i don't care how and who's tool and
the opportunity
to lower the barrier to doing that is is
great and again it's a lot of an
efficiency thing people
you know the end user you know needs to
be able to do these things
relatively efficiently we can't slow
sign a publication down to a crawl
or else people get upset so we need to
be efficient
and deliver them the ability to do these
things going forward
david kennedy thank you so much for
sharing your thoughts on reproducible
science that is
a fantastic amount of work i really
appreciate you sharing that with us
today
everyone who joined us thank you so much
everybody enjoy your weekend
and we'll look forward to seeing you
next week thanks again